impfstoff beschaffung verteidigt die eu
habe genügend dosen für deutschland
bestellt sagt der gesundheitsminister
das impf tempo nimmt langsam zu chaos
mit ansage beim digitalen lernens
scheitern schüler und lehrer oft an
überlasteten servern und software
problemen und mega prozess gegen die
mafia in italien stehen hunderte
mitglieder der kalabrischen 'ndrangheta
vor gericht
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und
willkommen zum nachrichtenüberblick an
diesem mittwoch schön dass sie dabei
sind wir auch norbert lehmann für den
sport von bülows familie
die kritik war deutlich tempo und
logistik der korona impfungen seien
beschämend wann hört es endlich auf zu
ruckeln der gesundheitsminister musste
sich im bundestag einiges anhören jens
spahn selbstvertrauen in die impfung und
appellierte eindringlich daran weiterhin
zusammenzustehen
das land befinde sich in einer der
schwersten phasen der pandemie aus
berlin patricia wiedemeier ja es würde
ruckeln bei der größten impfkampagne der
geschichte das gab gesundheitsminister
sparen heute zu um dann aber sofort
seinen eingeschlagenen weg zu
verteidigen
das europäische vorgehen bei der
beschaffung der impfstoffe den
europäischen weg zu gehen liegt im
nationalen interesse deutschlands und
unserer bürgerinnen und bürger
es ist eine frage der ökonomischen
vernunft dass wir nicht einzelne
nationen sondern ganz europa impfen
er ist so kommen wir wirtschaftlich
wieder auf die beine man habe genügend
impfstoff bestellt es sei eine frage der
produktionskapazitäten nicht der
verträge das ist derzeit nicht so voran
gehe
fdp und auch spd sehen das ganz anders
deutschland hätte während seiner
ratspräsidentschaft darauf drängen
müssen dass die eu mehr ordert wenn man
über europa spricht muss man fragen
warum die europäische union 750
milliarden euro für wirtschaftshilfe
aufwendet und auf der anderen seite bei
der beschaffung von ihm stoff knausert
angesichts der sozialen und ökonomischen
kosten die das schließen das
runterfahren dieses landes hätte sind
die kosten für die beschaffung des
impfstoffes eine lappalie eine wirkliche
lappalie wir hätten es machen müssen der
gesellschaft gehe die puste aus mehr
aufklärung mehr soforthilfen fordert die
opposition
es geht nicht dass eltern jetzt wochen
und monate lang sich weiterhin sowohl im
home office als auch um homeschooling
ihrer kinder kümmern müssen das kann so
nicht weitergehen
für die afg versagt die regierung
komplett der locker und sei nicht
alternativlos
wir reden von über 10.000 todesfällen in
alten und pflegeheimen das ungefähr ein
drittel aller mit oder an corinna
verstorbenen menschen in deutschland
und diese menschen müssen wir schützen
anstatt ein ganzes land in den
stillstand zu versetzen meine damen und
herren
trotz aller kritik auch wenn es derzeit
noch ruckelt beim impfen bis zum sommer
könne sich jeder der wolle impfen lassen
versprach der gesundheitsminister am
ende seiner rede die aktuelle corona
lage ist schwer einzuschätzen denn die
daten sind immer noch unvollständig das
robert koch institut meldet binnen eines
tages 19.600 neun infektionen und warnt
vor allem bei den jüngeren zwischen 15
und 39 jahren seien die zahlen deutlich
gestiegen
in verbindung mit dem virus gibt es 1000
60 neue todesfälle geimpft wurden über
69.000 menschen so viele wie noch nie an
einem tag
insgesamt sind es jetzt rund 700 58.000
0,91 prozent der bevölkerung
bislang hat der shutdown offenbar keine
große wirkung gezeigt die
infektionszahlen sind nach wie vor zu
hoch die wichtige frage deshalb was kann
neben der impfung noch helfen um die
pandemie in den griff zu bekommen
christoph distel berichtet es geht voran
mit dem impfen ab heute auch in
thüringer impfzentren trotzdem wird es
noch monate dauern bis die spritze zur
schärfsten waffen gegen das virus wird
solange müssen andere her zum beispiel
die ffb zwei masken pflicht findet
bayern
die soll dort ab kommender woche in
bussen bahnen und geschäften gelten was
natürlich auch bedeutet alltags oder
mediziner maske sind da nicht mehr genug
juristisch gesagt verboten das wird
helfen ist sich der ministerpräsident
sicher gegenüber den ganzen lächerlichen
charles die da zum teil sind und
ungefähr acht monaten getragenen
community die masten wie man findet
gerade im öpnv ist eine f e p2 maske in
jeder beziehung eine deutliche
verbesserung gute idee meinen auch die
die sich mit masken auskennen warnen
aber gleichzeitig die falsche form
männer bärte so viel kann schief laufen
mit einer fb2 die nicht richtig anlegt
und am rand luft leckagen lässt
neben ist wenn ich eine maske habe die
leckagen an der seite auf beißt dann
bestimmt die luft eben diese leckagen
vollkommen ungefiltert und dann bringt
so eine ft2 maske gegebenenfalls auch
nicht mehr als eine herkömmliche stoff
wasser und es wird ja auch nicht billig
eine ffp 2 gibt's kaum unter 2 euro
bayerns verantwortliche versprechen
gratis masken für bedürftige
nur wer ist bedürftig es dürfte
kompliziert werden allen fährt zu helfen
dann die zweite maßnahme des tages
möglichst keine weiteren coronaviren
mehr ins land lassen wie hier am
flughafen nürnberg gilt ab jetzt eine
neue verordnung und die zielt vor allem
auf die hochrisiko länder in denen
mutierter viren grassieren von da kommt
muss man schon vor der einreise einen
frischen negativen corona attest
vorlegen
reisende aus den übrigen risikogebieten
müssen ihren test spätestens 48 stunden
nach ihrer ankunft parat haben und für
alle zusammen gilt zehn tage quarantäne
nach ankunft in deutschland sind pflicht
in einem sind sich alle einig jetzt vor
dem großen impfen lassen sich die hohen
infektionszahlen nur mit einem klugen
mix der anderen maßnahmen drücken
schüler und lehrer müssen im moment
digital zusammenfinden mit hilfe von
komplexen computersysteme
solche lernplattformen sollen einen
virtuellen klassenraum schaffen und
müssen vieles können etwa
arbeitsmaterial bereitstellen
gemeinsames lernen per video ermöglichen
leistungen abfragen und bewerten
allerdings häufen sich technische
probleme server stürzen ab der frust ist
groß
aus hamburg sein bieten anna simeon esco
ist dem abiturjahrgang an einem
hamburger gymnasium wie die meisten
schüler lernt sie derzeit von zu hause
vor kurzem hat sie die schule gewechselt
und damit auch die lernplattform obwohl
beide einrichtungen in hamburg sind an
meiner schule hatten wir ein
und ja das ist so ähnlich wie für mich
ein bisschen komplizierter und das hat
auch oft überhaupt nicht funktionieren
aber du kannst jetzt mein bildschirm
sehen die videokonferenzen dieser schule
läuft über teams damit gab es noch keine
probleme
dazu kommt eine lernplattform die es
auch in bremen und schleswig holstein
gibt es learning eine international
etablierte software die ihren preis hat
wir brauchen die die professionelle
unterstützung sonst kommen wir aus dem
modus des bastelns des probierens des
nach steuern kommen wir nicht heraus
tatsächlich überlassen ist fast alle
bundesländer den schulen welche systeme
sie nutzen systeme die anfang der woche
abgestürzt überlastet oder in teilen
offline waren da braucht man sehr viel
datenspeicher den man auch hoch
skalieren kann unter skalieren kann wenn
man nicht so viel los ist und das kostet
geld
hinzu kommt uneinheitlichkeit rheinland
pfalz etwa schafft microsoft produkte an
den schulen aus datenschutzgründen ab
bayern hat sie gerade erst eingeführt
überhaupt nutzen die schulen zurzeit
alle möglichkeiten
leider stellt sich die situation
manchmal so dar dass die funktionieren
sind systeme datenschutztechnisch
bisschen problematisch sind und man
eigentlich als schulleiter manchmal die
wahl hat zwischen es funktioniert oder
dem datenschutz kann genüge getan werden
und das ist schon frustrierend zu sehen
einer 7 sq hat sich mit moodle der
plattform ihrer neuen schule arrangiert
jetzt fehlt mir nur noch eins ein
funktionierendes wlan zu hause
gesetzlich versicherte bekommen mehr
kinderkrankengeld wenn ihr kind zu hause
betreut werden muss gestern gab das
kabinett grünes licht für den
entsprechenden gesetzentwurf
konkret soll jedes elternteil zehn
zusätzliche tage beanspruchen können
alleinerziehende 20 so viel ist klar
doch wie sieht das in der praxis aus
wissen eltern und schulen und kitas wie
es funktioniert alexander rath hat sich
umgehört wie ein schlüssel bringt seine
söhnchen oscar und karl heute in die
kita der selbstständige elektriker kann
auf die betreuung kaum verzichten
seine frau ist angestellte sie würde das
kinderkrankengeld durchaus mal in
anspruch nehmen nur wie man dran kommt
sie nicht das heißt ich würde jetzt
wahrscheinlich erst mal bei einer
krankenkasse anrufen weil es ist ja ein
krankengeld also da würde ich mich dann
erstmal informieren wollen
und ansonsten würde ich vielleicht den
weg zur einrichtungsleitung gehen aber
ich glaube da sind die nicht im bilde
und sind wir wohl auch erstmal so ein
bisschen auf uns gestellt zu gucken wo
da die information mehr bekommen
die kita-leiterin war es tatsächlich
nicht mehr dabei sollen kitas künftig
bescheinigungen ausstellen die zum
geldbezug berechtigen
ich wüsste auch gar nicht was da alles
rein muss weil das ist ja eine
gesetzliche sache und da bin ich
eigentlich das kleinste licht am ende
des tunnels fakt ist gezahlt wird auch
wenn die kita auf ist aber die behörden
vom besuch ab raten bis maximal 113 euro
am tag
der anspruch auf insgesamt 20 tage pro
kind und elternteil für alleinerziehende
40 tage
die regelung gilt für kinder bis zwölf
jahre der anspruch gilt aber nur für
gesetzlich versicherte
der weg der jetzt gefunden wurde von der
bundesregierung ist unbürokratisch es
muss zwar ein nachweis erbracht werden
aber formlos wenn man den bei uns ein
reicht dann fließt auch das geld so der
plan familienvater jan füßl muss ich
darauf erst einmal verlassen zwei
amtsenthebungsverfahren in einer
amtszeit das gab es noch nie in der
geschichte der usa noch heute wollen die
demokraten das historische zweite
verfahren gegen präsident jump offiziell
beschließen anstiftung zum aufruhr
lautet die anklage
nach dem blutigen sturm der jump
anhänger auf das kapitol und immer mehr
republikaner stellen sich gegen john aus
den usa ins trasse die soldaten der
nationalgarde werden mit waffen
ausgestattet der kongress rüstet sich
für all das was da kommt einige der
soldaten campieren bereits im gebäude
des kapitols am abend hatte
vizepräsident pence klargemacht er wird
nicht wie von den demokraten gefordert
präsident traum für amtsunfähig erklären
er glaube nicht dass ein solches
vorgehen im besten interesse unserer
nation ist oder im einklang mit der
verfassung steht
entsprechend machen die demokraten im
abgeordnetenhaus nun ernst
sie beginnen mit dem
amtsenthebungsverfahren gegen lang wegen
anstiftung zum aufruhr mindestens fünf
republikaner zehn mit den präsidenten
davonkommen zu lassen obwohl er den
angriff angestiftet hat gefährdet unsere
demokratie
deswegen werde ich für eine
amtsenthebung stimmen sogar der
republikanische mehrheitsführer des
senats mitch mcconnell so heißt es würde
ein image mit begrüßen damit rückt auch
die notwendige zweidrittelmehrheit im
senat für eine amtsenthebung er trump
versucht derweil abzulenken gestern
besuchte er die mauer an der grenze zu
mexiko verächtlich äußerte er sich zum
amtsenthebungsverfahren doppeldeutig
warnte er
seid vorsichtig was ihr euch wünscht
eine amtsenthebung verursacht große wut
spaltung und schmerz größer als viele
leute jemals verstehen werden
das ist gefährlich für die vereinigten
staaten gerade in dieser fragilen zeit
derweil verfasst der generalstab im
pentagon ein memo die generäle fühlen
sich bemüßigt zu erklären
das militär verteidige immer die
verfassung gegen aus und inländische
feinde
es ist davon auszugehen dass das
abgeordnetenhaus ortszeit washington am
nachmittag zum zweiten mal ein
amtsenthebungsverfahren gegen trump
beschließt noch bis sonntag ist
kremlkritiker alexej nawalny in
deutschland dann will er nach russland
zurück fliegen
in einem online video sagte der
44-jährige erfülle sich fast gesund
dabei nie war hier behandelt worden
nachdem er während einer reise in
russland vergiftet worden war
da waren die macht dafür die regierung
in moskau verantwortlich
der kreml weist die vorwürfe zurück in
moskau warum kehrt alexej nawalny in
seiner heimat zurück obwohl er um seine
freiheit und möglicherweise ja auch um
sein leben fürchten muss
aus nabu sicht wäre es eine niederlage
wenn er sich jetzt aus russland
ausschließen lassen würde
aber ja dem kreml-kritiker droht eine
mehrjährige haftstrafe und es scheint
möglich dass er noch am flughafen
abgeführt wird
allerdings könnte dieses dann wenn er
tatsächlich dieter hapel haft käme dann
könnte er keinen politischen einfluss
nehmen auf die parlamentswahlen die hier
im herbst stattfinden allerdings könnte
das dem kreml als unsicherheit als
schwäche ausgelegt werden wenn es wenn
er jetzt versuchen würde seinen
politischen gegner auf diese art und
weise aus dem verkehr zu ziehen
andererseits die bilder einer
triumphalen rückkehr die wird man
derweil die auch nicht gönnen wollen
bisher ist es so dass die vergiftung von
alexei navalny die breite russische
öffentlichkeit ziemlich kalt gelassen
hat und für den kreml wäre es gut wenn
auch in zukunft kein emotionales band
wächst zwischen dem oppositionellen und
der wählerschaft dafür darf alexei
navalny jetzt weder zum helden noch zum
märtyrer werden live aus moskau vielen
dank es war schon erwartet worden in
italien ist die regierungskoalition
geplatzt der frühere ministerpräsident
matteo renzi hat seine unterstützung
aufgekündigt und zwei ministerinnen aus
der regierung abgezogen
die koalition unter ministerpräsident
konnte hat nun keine ausreichende
mehrheit mehr im parlament
unabhängig von der regierungskrise
begann im süden italiens eine der
größten mafia prozesse der geschichte
gegen die kalabrische n'drangheta ein
mega verfahren seit jahren vorbereitet
in einem extra gebauten bunker als
gerichtsgebäude auf der anklagebank mehr
als 350 mutmaßliche mafiosi darunter
politiker und geschäftsleute dazu 900
zeugen prozessdauer mindestens ein jahr
annette hilsenbeck herrscht
alarmstimmung rund um das gelände wo
sich seit heute die angeklagten vor
gericht verantworten müssen sie sind zum
teil per videokonferenz zugeschaltet der
prozess ein erfolg der ermittler ein
enormer schlag gegen die mächtige
mafiaorganisation n'drangheta
vor ein paar jahrzehnten erlebte man
wenn man das wort cosa nostra oder einem
dran geht aus sprach diese worte wurden
nur geflüstert
heute sprechen wir offen über sie und
seit zwei jahren neben anzeigen von
unternehmern und bürgern gegen sie zu
die fahnder hatten im dezember 2009 10
ein gigantisches kriminelles netzwerk
ausgehoben das auch politik justiz und
wirtschaft in kalabrien unterwandert
hatte mehrere hundert clan mitglieder
wurden verhaftet die anklage jetzt unter
anderem erpressung mord drogenhandel
amtsmissbrauch und zugehörigkeit zu
einer mafiösen organisation ndrangheta
ersetzte den staat als justiz im
untergrund und auch in der wirtschaft
sie wurde aus zum ablösen sozialsystem
wo der stadt fehlte in kalabrien auch
nach deutschland reichen die kriminellen
aktivitäten der 'ndrangheta etwa
geldwäsche von einnahmen aus ihrem
verbrechen in deutschland kann jemand
mit geldkoffern aufkreuzen und niemand
interessiert ob er dieses geld mit
kokain menschlichen organen oder mit
sklaven verdient hat der jetzige prozess
ist ein erfolg im kampf gegen die
mächtigen brutalen dran gitter und eine
demonstration der staatsmacht
zum sport in ägypten hat die handball wm
begonnen norbert im schatten von coruña
die usa und tschechien haben ihre teams
zurückgezogen nach zahlreichen
infektionen in den beiden mannschaften
das deutsche team das hat heute die
hygienemaßnahmen vor ort kritisiert lena
goeßling in kairo um was geht's dabei es
geht um maske tragen und uns abstand
halten und darf hat im teamhotel der
deutschen mannschaft bisher nicht
besonders gut geklappt die kritik ist
das gerade beim essen viele verschiedene
mannschaften zusammen kommen zu eng
beieinander sitzen und alt das auch die
weitläufigkeit des hotels gar nicht
ausreichend genug genutzt wird wir haben
heute aber vom thw heute nachmittag die
nachricht bekommen dass es mittlerweile
eine erste lösung gibt es gibt einen
extra raum in dem das dhb team essen
kann da dann nur noch gemeinsam mit dem
norwegischen thema und während dieser ex
raum entdeckt wurde war die dhb auswahl
heute das erste mal hier in ägypten beim
training am freitag gegen uruguay und am
sonntag dann gegen die kapverden das
katholische team soll einige positive
corona fälle haben aber trotzdem
offenbar reisen sie jetzt doch nach
ägypten allerdings ohne sechs spieler
und auch ohne cheftrainer dank alina
kesting olympiasieger arnd peiffer hat
den deutschen biathleten beim weltcup
heimspiel in oberhof den ersten
podestplatz des neuen jahres gesichert
im sprint über zehn kilometer erkämpft
er sich bei schwierigen bedingungen dem
dritten platz vor seinem teamkollegen
erik lesser beide ohne schießfehler wenn
die rag doll auf rang elf der
norwegischen doppelerfolg wird einmal
mehr angeführt von johannes dinkelsbühl
seien 51 star weltcup-erfolg dfb-pokal
die beiden nachholspiele heute abend
trifft zweitligist holstein kiel auf den
deutschen meister bayern münchen gestern
abend das duell leverkusen gegen
frankfurt bayer gerät zunächst frühen
rückstand das 0 2 1 durch younes der
ausgleich durch lukas salami oder
umstrittenen handelfmeter in halbzeit
zwei drehte leverkusen auf add montag so
bat zum 2 2 1 aus ganz knapper
abseitsposition und danach trifft muss
er die harvey zweimal der 4 2 1 endstand
in der 87 minute leverkusen trifft im
achtelfinale auf regionalligist rot
weiss essen und frankfurt kann sich ja
damit trösten dass luca judith kurz vor
der rückkehr zur eintracht steht
immerhin und wir können jetzt vielleicht
noch jemand mit den lottozahlen
beglücken
sie lauten 7 23 26 38 40 43 und die
superzahl 6 weitere gewinnzahlen finden
sie auf lotto zdf de und im zdf text auf
seite 5 157
morgen geht's erst mal sonnig und kalt
weiter
mehr zum wetter hat gleich katja um
viertel vor zehn das heute journal mit
bettina schausten und einem gespräch mit
dem wirtschaftsminister
wir danken für ihr interesse und
wünschen ihnen noch einen unbeschwerten
schulden abend bis morgen wenn siemens
[Musik]
knaben meine damen und herren da zogen
ja heute kräftige schnee schnee regen
und graupelschauer vor allen dingen über
den nordosten deutschlands und da waren
auch tatsächlich kräftige winter
gewitter dabei zum beispiel in
niedersachsen aber auch in mecklenburg
vorpommern und in brandenburg und mit
diesen kräftigen schauern geht es jetzt
auch in der nacht weiter
dazu wird ein starker bis stürmischer
wind da müssen sie sich also auch auf
schnee verwehungen gefasst machen selbst
in berlin könnten bis morgen früh
durchaus fünf zentimeter neuschnee
fallen
auch an den alpen wird es kräftig
schneien besonders in der zweiten
nachthälfte tief winterliche
straßenverhältnisse gibt es aber
eigentlich überall bei
tiefsttemperaturen zwischen minus fünf
und plus drei grad und morgen liegen die
höchsttemperaturen zwischen minus zwei
und plus vier grad am oberrhein und es
gibt noch letzte schauer an der
ostseeküste vor allen dingen aber auch
am nordrand des erzgebirges viel
spannendes aber der schnee hier im
südwesten zwischen dem schwarzwald und
im allgäu können morgen oberhalb von 800
meter bis zum abend 50 cm neuschnee
fallen
deutlich freundlicher wird es von der
nordseeküste bis zum einen da scheint
nämlich auch mal die sonne der wind ist
immer noch recht kräftig kommt aus
nördlichen richtungen
am freitag schneit es nur noch leicht
der samstag wird trocken und der sonntag
von westen deutlich milder schönen abend
noch